في تطور اخر نقلت شبكه روسيانا عن
مسؤولينا امريكيين واخراريين ان حلفاء
اوكرانيا الغربيين يحرثونها على تغيير
تكتيكاتها في القتال المستمر منذ اشهر في
مدينه بهبط واعطاء الاولويه بدلا عن حرب
الاستنزاف الطاحنه لهجوم محتمل في الجنوب
باستخدام اسلوب مختلف من القتال عبر
الاستفاده من المعدات العسكريه الجديده
التي ارسلها لها الغرب وامريكا وقالت
الشبكه نقلا عن المسؤولين مطلعين ان هذا
الحلفاء الغربيين اوكرانيا على تغيير
تكتيكاتها ياتي وسط مؤشرات على ان الرئيس
الروسي يدرس اتخاذ خطوه كبيره في الاسابيع
القليله المقبله لاستعاده زمام المبادره
في الحرب وحسب مصادر مطلعه لسينان تم
سماعه بعض كبار المسؤولين العسكريين الروس
في الاسابيع الاخيره وهم يناقشون امكانيه
محاوله استعاده مدينه